Stephen Cohen good morning to you thanks
for being with us with the Brookings
Institution also the author of India
emerging power tomorrow President Bush
will be meeting with India's Prime
Minister what's what will come out of
this meeting I don't think there'll be
any specific concrete agreements reach
there's a few things that they're going
to be signing but I think that the
United States wants to reassure India
that we haven't abandoned ooh Delhi and
that we're gonna we see India's it as a
long-range investment for the United
States and long-range terms of strategic
economic and even the ideological
relationship with the United States for
the next 45 minutes we want to learn
more about this country our relations
with India and also its history based on
the work of Stephen Cohen our phone
lines will be open you can also email us
at journal at c-span org you begin
chapter 3 this way for many foreign
officials dealing with New Delhi can be
a frustrating experience Western
diplomats were for many years put off by
India's flexible non-alignment which for
a time was a pretext for a close
relationship with the Soviet Union
they were also irritated by the style of
Indian diplomats while professional and
competent they seemed compelled to
lecture their British or American
counterparts on the evils of the Cold
War the moral superiority of India's
policies or the greatness of its
civilization can you elaborate well for
many years India the Indian leadership
has seen itself as a great state and one
of the great civilizations of the world
this was this was stated most fully by
Jawaharlal Nehru India's first prime
minister but I think it's widely
accepted among Indian intellectuals and
Indian diplomats of course Sharon that
perception yet India as a state and as a
country was not a wealthy country and
compared with the Americans or with the
Brits or with even the Japanese recently
it really lagged behind but I think this
discrepancy between Indian ambitions and
Indian perceptions of themselves as
truly at one of the world's five or six
major civilizations and the reality of
India having more than half of the
world's poor people really led them to
in a sense and still does lead them to
exaggerate the and then to present
themselves as morally more superior to
others and I think that's what really
rubbed the Americans the wrong one sense
of moral superiority that Indians the
Indian officials in particular let's
scar the map and get a geographic sense
of this country first of all how large
is it how many people live there
India has about population is about Oh
1.3 billion people now they're catching
up with the Chinese and in 20 years or
so they're expected to surpass China the
size of India India's roughly about 3/4
of the size of the United States so you
have three or three times as many people
four times as many people in a space
that it's that's smaller than the United
States and what form of government does
it have
India has a parliamentary democracy that
is most Indians live under a relatively
free country free government have all
that all the rights associated with
democracy there are some parts of India
which are not democratic which are
essentially under either military or
porous or administrative rule our
American companies based in India do we
do business with several hundred
American corporations based in India but
it has not been a significant source of
American investment and this is changing
rapidly as American Native American
businesses and corporations discover
India and as India itself liberalizes
its economy you also write in reference
to the government of India that the
constitution of the country confers upon
the president the nominal position of
commander-in-chief but in actuality it's
the Prime Minister and the cabinet's
which dominate foreign policymaking you
also write that their authority derives
from a parliamentary majority Parliament
votes the defense in foreign affairs
budget annually and individual members
or parties may compel the government to
respond to questions or enter the
cursory debate and Parliament has little
voice in the routine conduct of foreign
policy why is that well it's a
parliamentary system it's fundamentally
different than our system where
Parliament is controlled by the majority
political party in this case that's a
coalition of parties headed by the
brought to janitor party and other other
parties and once you have a majority you
don't need to go back to Parliament for
day to day day to day affirmation of
your policies in a sense you control the
Parliament and and and it's it's very
similar to Great Britain or in Japan
where the where the doubt majority party
could really make policy any way it
wants to but Parliament does have some
influence around along the margins it's
not central to policymaking
but it can influence Indian policymaking
along the edges especially in question
time the Indian Prime Minister has to
subject himself to response to questions
of from the opposition opposition
patches do you know by chance if cameras
are allowed in the Indian
I think it's an Indian Parliament is
televised yes he opens it up explain the
relationship or lack thereof between
Pakistan and India Pakistan was part of
British India and when the British left
India in 1947 they could not work out an
arrangement by which the the largely
Muslim parts of British India would stay
within India so there was a partition of
British India and a good chunk of it
maybe a quarter if it went off and
became the country of Pakistan a
Pakistan was founded on the basis of
being a homeland for Indian Muslims
India of course is a secular state in
which all religions are treated equally
I think there's a fundamental problem
here because the identity of Pakistan as
an Islamic state contradicts the
identity of India as a secular state and
vice versa and that's one of the basic
reasons why they've been they've had a
conflict for over fifty three years
there's out there other reasons also for
this fundamental difference in identity
really causes problems I don't think
it's in a central I don't think the
conflict is inevitable but it's like a
Protestant country and a Catholic
country were the identities of the two
states do very consider our guest is
Stephen Cohen he is out with a book on
India as an emerging power our phone
number is two zero two seven three seven
zero zero zero one if you are democrat
to zero to seven three seven zero zero
to four Republicans and two oh two six
to eight oh two oh five if you're a
member of a third party going back to
this issue between India and Pakistan
you say that for more than 40 years
Indian policy was devoted to the
reduction of the American presence in
Asia not because India was anti-american
but because the US presence made it
difficult for India to extend its own
influence you go on to say from New
Delhi's perspective bringing Pakistan
into the American orbit was the worst
consequence of the Cold War that's right
why well when India achieved
independence in 1947 the Indian
leadership assumed that they would they
would inherit the dominant role that
British India had had in Asia and
British India dominated that part of
Asia from the Persian Gulf all the way
to Southeast Asia and with in the cold
the Cold War brought the Americans into
South into Southeast Asia and the Indian
Ocean area this in a sense preempted
India's role as the as a preamp
prevented India from emerging as the
predominant power in the Indian Ocean
region and I think that was the major
consequence of the Cold War for India
not that they were anti-american but
that they
did not like to see us supporting
Pakistan which was a cold war an ally
and this this undercut Indian power you
there's also forwards in on page 259
Pakistan is China's Israel explain what
you're talking about
yeah Pakistan is the most devoted most
faithful ally of China dharna Pakistan
has received more economic and technical
assistance from China than Chinese given
to any other country in the world so the
analogy is between the United States and
Israel and China and Pakistan and both
of them serve important strategic
strategic objectives for the for the
dominant power we see Israel as a force
for stability in the Middle East the
Chinese see the Pakistanis as a way of
balancing out in the old days balancing
out Soviet power but now balancing out
Indian power and also the Chinese see
Pakistan as an entry point into the
Middle East into the Islamic world the
book looks like emerging power our guest
is Stephen Cohen good morning where you
phoning from Hospital Georgia
go ahead please yes mr. Cohen thanks for
coming to c---span I'm really glad that
you pointed out the parliamentary system
that they have over there and the only
model I really knew up with Germany's
where you have these various coalition's
and everything like that that none of
them have the majority so they can't
swing it let's swing the public policy
one way or the other but they have to
compromise with another party to you
know gain a foothold other maggiore next
call Marion Ohio good morning yes how
are you this morning I've been reading
some of the history about that area and
when he mentioned from the Persian to
Indochina the British how they divided
up those areas and even the British were
involved in partitioning out what
Israel's boundaries would be did they
intentionally for some political reason
divide them up with these conflicts
between these the tribal things like in
Pakistan and that and dividing out when
they live and potential divided up
Israel he cut across part of the
Palestinian area and they did so did
they do so with malevolent intentions
did they sort it was that like tongue
and
sort of like well here's what you get
when you get your independent no I I
don't believe so I've talked to a number
of former British officials my first
book is on the Indian Army and did a lot
of interviewing in London thirty years
ago forty almost forty years ago now
talk to a lot of people who involved in
these things I don't think they were
malevolent but they did want to ensure
that there would be a balance power in
in these regions as they left in the
case of Pakistan in Israel I think there
was an assembler there were some strong
similarities each was a state founded on
the principle for religion and the
British wanted to protect that help
protect that religion in the case of in
case of Israel Jews in the case of
Pakistan Muslims this of course led to
conflict with with the within it with it
with the neighbors India and in one case
in the Arab states and the other case
but I don't think the British had a
malevolent intent but they did certainly
want to retain influence in these
regions and in the case of Pakistan
there were many Brits who saw Pakistan
as a potential ally Britain and there
were more suspicious of the Indian
nationalist leadership or less Wow who
odd most of them were educated in
Britain but they were not going to
subordinate themselves to British
strategic designs York Pennsylvania good
morning to you for Stephen Cohen yes I'm
so thankful that we have an expert on
India it's a very important in the break
strategic area of the world which is
discussion on the question of an
electoral college now as you know India
does have a parliamentary system and one
of the arguments made is that a
parliamentary system isn't as stable as
an electoral college will you comment on
would an electoral college for India be
more strong or do you think that the
parliamentary system is the only way for
India there's been a debate in India for
the past ten years because for the past
ten years the Indian Indian government
has been government been dominated by
different kinds of coalition's that has
no single political party has been able
to obtain a majority for the first five
years there was a lot of instability and
governments rose and fell there were I
think over four prime ministers in three
years it was very unstable and the
Indians themselves were talking about
moving to a presidential system where
you have a strong executive leader as in
the United States or France but I think
they passed that period the Indians have
learned both at the national level and
also at the state level there they're
2025 Indian state governments as well
some of which have over 150 million
people they've learned to be able to put
together these political coalition's and
run reasonably effective governments in
fact when you have a coalition
government in your d-type decide a
policy that generally gets more
acceptance across the board and it tends
to it can tends to endure a little bit
longer and if you have a party that just
does it and then leaves then another the
opposition party comes in so I think the
Indians have been able to manage his
complexity reasonably well when did when
did India begin acquiring nuclear
nuclear technology and why India
actually began to acquire nuclear
technology before it was independent
there were Indian Indian scientists who
were interested in nuclear energy for
civilian purposes but then for military
purposes in the 1930s in the 1940s after
India became independent a small
research program began headed towards
these civilian power reactor program in
the United States in fact sold India one
of its major power reactors and helped
trained a number of Indian scientists
the military nuclear program probably
began sometime in the 60s there was a
covert program secretly done India never
admitted until actually conducted test
that it was that it had a military
nuclear program and that program led to
the to the to a first day a pretend
civilian test in 1974 which was actually
a military test and then then a series
of nuclear weapons test in 1998 page 135
the chapter India is a military power
your right quote well Indira Gandhi was
a nationalist like her father she was
also more insecure in dealing with the
rest of the world and had a greater
willingness to link military force to
political power you also say she remains
the most militaristic politician ever to
become Prime Minister of India that's
right I mean she actually criticized her
father Jawaharlal Nehru for being a
saint who wandered into politics and
narrow had a lot of self-restraint he
had he had ultimate political power in
India but he did not exercise it
she was quite generous in terms of
consulting with even the opposition
parties she is farmed when she was far
more ruthless lady and she used force of
course to divide Pakistan in the 1970
war and I think she was the one in
introduced business applying with ethnic
rifles in India sort of a balance of
power politics which ultimately resulted
in her being assassinated by Sikh by her
Sikh bodyguards who were angry with the
way in which she did play politics with
a Sikh community when was she killed she
was killed in the year was
19 subject just escaped my mind it was
must have been 1964 6500 next call is
New York City good morning hi how are
you doing thanks for coming to see span
in drag Andy was killed in 84 by the way
okay I was talking about the
parliamentary system that we were
dealing with the for I think
parliamentary system doesn't mean
correlation in India coalition is there
because their multi-party system in
America you don't get coalition because
you have two very strong parties do you
have any comments about that well in
fact in some of the states we have the
way the American system operates is that
in many cases with Republicans running
one part of the government and Democrats
running another part of the government
it is an effective coalition in India
you do have coalition system now because
there is no dominant party but but that
coalition has to get a majority in the
parliament has to get 50 percent plus
one of the votes in a parliament in
order to stay in power and the reason
the end the BJP in particular has been
able to put together coalition's which
have been able to maintain themselves in
power is you look at this map can you
point to the area known as Kashmir yes
Kashmir would be right here yeah it's
marked in green here it's it's it's
drawn as part of India but also part of
Pakistan and the very identity of
Kashmir is being Indian or Pakistani or
independent is a subject subject to a
great controversy and we can we can do
several programs on that the Indians
claim all Kashmir is entirely Indian the
Pakistani claim is that the Kashmir
needs to have a public site to determine
which way it would go whether we'd go to
India or do Pakistan or become an
independent country as we study Indian
politics from an American perspective is
this important it's important because
Kashmir is one of the major unresolved
issues in the world
the Kashmiri dispute goes back to the
1940s when it was first taken to the
United Nations by India in fact and it
is a possible flashpoint for a larger
conflict between India and Pakistan
they're tremendous human rights
violations in Kashmir committed not only
by the Indian government which is
responsible for some of them but also by
a huge band of Islamic extremists who
who've invaded Kashmir coming over from
Pakistan and Afghanistan the Kashmiri
people are subject to tremendous I'd say
human rights abuses of the worst organ
Charles Krauthammer and
other colonists have been referring to
an on-again off-again relationship with
Pakistan would you agree that that's our
assessment towards that country yeah a
friend of mine Michael kraepelin has
characterized this as saying we're
between divorces with Pakistan how would
you describe India in our relationship
with India in the case of India we had a
long estrangement in the 1950s 1960s
early 1960s we saw India as the major
Asian democracy and there was a
tremendous amount of American economic
and military assistance to New Delhi by
the night by the mid-1960s we were
disillusioned with India we grew we
drifted away from India and by the 1970s
we began to see China as the major Asian
power to cultivate now again we've
reversed our course we're the Bush
administration was more critical of
China and began to favor India of course
the terrorist bombings of September they
changed that policy again but from the
Indian perspective we have come and gone
several times they see us as do the
Pakistanis as they felt very fickle
power as we take this next call from
Atlanta we want to show you the website
the organization the Stephen Cohen
represents the Brookings Institution
where he is a senior fellow he's also
the author of India emerging power the
web address is Brookings dot e-d-u
Atlanta go ahead please hi I'm going to
find out what if any difference there is
between how Europe views minority
religions which are recognized as true
religions in other areas such as Jehovah
Witnesses sort of Church of Scientology
or something like that how India treats
minority religions Indian record on
treating minority religions or there's
non majority religions of religions
other than Hinduism because you can do
with Hinduism is the dominant religion
of India although it's not the official
religion of India Indian record is very
very good embedded in the Indian
Constitution is protection of all of all
religions and there's a huge huge
Christian population there's a
significant eye Ganic Muslim population
India has the third of the fourth the
world's third or fourth largest number
of Muslims in it there's a tiny Jewish
population and there are other other
important religions in India in recent
years have been problems that is some of
him some Hindu extremists have begun to
attack these other religions especially
Christians and Muslims the Hindu
extremists have argued that these are
alien religions that these are religions
they
came to India to conquer and to convert
it both Islam and Christianity and that
there's the implication is that Indian
Christians and Indian Muslims should
reconvert back to Hinduism and this has
created a number of significant riots
and I'd say terrible events in Indian
India over the past ten years our guest
is also the author of a book called the
Pakistan Army and he edited nuclear
proliferation in South Asia which came
out 11 years ago next call from Queens
in New York good morning hi good morning
my name is Lucifer Arkham and I have two
questions number one the previous caller
said about the the Hindu extremists
behavior with the minorities in India I
believe they're more than 200,000 Sikhs
have been killed
in India 250,000 Christians have been
killed
150,000 Muslims according to one of the
reports and again since India tries to
behave like one of the biggest democracy
in the world don't you think mr. Cohen
that India should abide by the solutions
of United Nations to hold prep a certain
Kashmir in order to give the right to
the people to choose their independence
yeah you've asked several questions let
me say that Stephen perhaps there should
be a pro Indian line and a pro Pakistani
line and perhaps a pro-american call-in
line you know it's not Republican or
Democrat this is the sense partisanship
let me strongly disagree with the
figures you cited you may have gotten
those from some source but it doesn't
come anything close to the figures I'm
familiar with it clearly there been
atrocities committed against Sikhs
against Muslims against Christians in in
India and these are regrettable and they
but they are they're much the numbers
are much smaller than the ones you have
indicated and by for the most part the
Indian government is investigating and
attempting to punish the people involved
for these in some cases the perpetrators
are linked to the Indian government or
have political connections this has not
happened but I don't think the numbers
you've given are correct in the in the
case of Kashmir I do think that there
has to be something done about Kashmir
I'm not sure if going back to the UN
resolutions is the answer but the
Indians have been irresponsible in
allowing this issue to drag on and on
there are their defenses that they've
been provoked by Pakistan which has fed
armed terrorists across the border into
Kashmir I think I think this is an area
where all parties have have some
responsibility but I don't think it's in
the American interest at least to allow
this to drag on much longer because
Kashmir could become a flashpoint for
another conventional war between the two
countries it's an area of human rights
violations and also there's a potential
for nuclear conflicts between the
between India and Pakistan so I think
this is a matter of international
concern I think if there's a settlement
then the Pakistanis will be disappointed
the Pakistani seem to want the whole hog
they would that's actually a bad
metaphor when talking about Muslims this
Pakistani seemed to want the one Kashmir
for themselves
I don't think India under any
circumstances will yield Kashmir but
many Indians are willing to compromise
really or at least to discuss a
compromise I think you need to get a
dialogue between Indians and Pakistanis
and Kush marries to discuss the shape of
a future arrangement for country our
conversation is with Stephen Cohen our
topic is India mr. Cohen spent some time
in New Delhi as a scholar at the Ford
Foundation is also a former professor at
the University of Illinois at Urbana
next call is from Atlanta good morning
good morning my name is Quran mr. Cohen
I really enjoyed listening to you the
question I had was what do you think
about the new tilt towards the the
Americans seem to tilt towards Pakistan
at this point of time is there a problem
the way India perceives the United
States tilting towards Pakistan
you know because India actually believes
it's a democracy on one hand and they
see the dictatorship in Pakistan and
they think you know they see all the
platitudes being served by every
administration and they they they feel
somehow I guess you know they're worried
about what's going on out there and now
you know you read reports that there are
arms being supplied to Pakistan so I
don't know I'll hang up and listen thank
you also add to today British Prime
Minister Tony Blair who yesterday met
with President Bush he's meeting with
General Musharraf in London today and
President Bush will meet with Bashar
from the 10th as he's meeting with bunch
by in the 9th so there's a lot of
high-level diplomacy going on right now
let me respond to your question by
saying a few things I don't think that
the India is quite the democracy that is
it's it's real fans
proclaim it to me there's a lot of
imperfections in Indian democracy I'd be
the first to acknowledge that there's a
lot of imperfections in American
democracy and democracy is an ideal in
which no state can really really really
reach that ideal fully but I think India
does reasonably well given its given its
handicaps and its problems the case of
Pakistan also Pakistan is not a military
dictatorship in the classic sense of the
world or pukka the the the present
government headed by President Musharraf
General Musharraf really was preceded by
ten years of incompetent democracy in
which there were human rights abuses in
which the press was constrained which
Pakistanis were beaten up on the streets
in many ways the present government is
more liberal government than its
predecessor under Nawaz Sharif so I
don't think you can paint these
countries in black and white
India's certainly gray a lighter shade
of gray Pakistan is a darker shade of
gray perhaps but I haven't given up on
Pakistan and I think the present the
decision of General Musharraf to abandon
the support for the Taliban it's a
tremendous impact on Pakistani domestic
politics and I think there's a chance to
see Pakistan emerge once again as a
coherent democracy so I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't pitch it in black
and white I mean I think the United I
think the United States strategic
relationship with Pakistan may be
temporary but I think we have a long
term interest in investing in Pakistan
civilian institutions to help Pakistan
emerge out from from it from military
rule to a more coherent and functional
parliamentary democracy it's off
good morning to Cleveland Ohio you're on
c-span go ahead good morning I'm
particularly concerned about the huge
population in India and China too of
course
and I wonder if if the the people are
offered contraception or if they are for
contraception something needs to be done
well you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make them drink and I think
the same thing applies to contraceptives
you can offer them but they're not
necessarily being used they're two
things that effect a country's birthrate
one is the education of its of its young
girls educating young girls can have a
tremendous impact on a country's birth
rate because educated young women do not
want to have a lot of children they can
get employment in their own right and
they understand the social and political
and economic cost of having a lot of
children so educating young girls young
young young girl children is a critical
decision that a lot of countries have
made Pakistan is moving in that
direction India does quite well in this
area
their parts have been to where the
literacy rate is now 90 or 100% the
other the other country the other really
effective contraceptive is is economic
growth and if you look at the Indian
birth rates around the country and its
ability as a country country up over a
billion people it's a laboratory in its
own right the areas which have had high
rates of education of young girls and
also high growth rates are the areas of
the lowest birth rates in fact in the
cities they're barely meeting
replacement replacement standards our
population so I think that this is a
problem that will take care of itself
readily if India grows economically and
if it continues to expand its
operational opportunities especially for
young women Milledgeville Georgia good
morning thanks for calling oh yes for
mister dr. cotton I have the following
comment India is a country with less
than one dollar 50 cent income per day
and the highest proportion of poor
people live in India and the education
rate is one of the lowest in the world
of course it has a big military power so
it looks like it is going to be an
emerging power like former Soviet Union
in making yeah I think that your figures
may be like slightly exaggerated but it
is true that India has over half of the
world's poorest people it also has a
good percentage of the world's smartest
and best educated people and one of the
paradoxes of India that I discuss in my
book is the phenomena of producing very
highly trained well-educated Indians
many of whom come to the United States
and in turn have entered into our
high-tech industry and also having a
vast illiterate population a percentage
of it the Indian Indian education rates
have gone up steadily but there has not
been enough done by the Indian
government to really promote this I
don't think that India I think that I
think that parts of India really looked
very developed and very advanced parts
of India such as the states of Witcher
Pradesh and Bihar are really quite
backward and very primitive
I think this internal gap within India
something that the Indian government
recognizes and they understand that the
only way to close that gap is not simply
by state intervention but by opening up
the economy and allowing the forest
areas of ended
to take advantage and grow economically
in rapidly Manchester New Hampshire good
morning good morning thank you stucco
hand hi my name is Benna Conger
I'm originally from Kenya and I grew up
with them lots of Indians probably might
not have East Africa and probably
southern Africa I've got lots of people
of Indian extraction and evidently
they're winner of the Nobel Prize for
Literature from the Caribbean
sub-regions night off now I've got a
question
India does not seem to avoid any
imperialistic tendencies but it has
exported a lot of people to the world
with great talent and how much and how
fat father can you look on and say
probably in the next 15 to 20 years in
there would be in terms of international
contribution to academia and science
that's a very good point that you make
India India's expansion has not been
military it's been cultural and to some
degree economic in the whole Indian
Ocean region including East Africa Kenya
you know have been greatly influenced by
India by an Indian emigrant emigration
this is very much like the traverses
Chinese a community that's dispersed all
around the world but especially in parts
of Asia I think that the India is India
used to regard it's human export as
simply disposable people the people
would ship out in the hundreds of
thousands to live in other parts of the
world now I think the Indian government
view has changed and many of this Dyess
many of this Indian diaspora is seen as
an asset for India and many overseas
Indians are coming back to India
investing in India and developing a new
relationship with India I think VS
Naipaul is a good example of this he's
written several books about India the
first one was terribly critical of India
second and third books I think we're
more more balanced about what's
happening in India what are among
India's leading exports
first of all human talent I mean a
tremendous exporter of highly educated
skilled people but secondly the usual
raw materials cotton Goods textiles
India exports I think it's now 50 or 60
maybe 100 million dollars worth of
software a year most of it to the United
States and these these kinds of exports
are growing rapidly
the Indians fell far behind China in
terms of its industrial export output
and the Indians have a lot of catching
up to do and in terms of being a modern
industrial state which can export
finished goods to the rest of the world
but in handicrafts carpets and so forth
India fulfills an important role in many
countries good morning to Chicago go
ahead please good morning my question to
Stephen is that India is now
economically liberalizing this lure of
liberalisation going on there is huge
disparity in income between India do you
think this would cause problems maybe in
further elections where there could be a
backlash against economic liberalisation
and people would go back to the old
system of protectionism and you know
guaranteeing workers jobs no things like
that that's an important question
because this is something that's much
debated in India but I think that
there's general consensus across the
political spectrum that the
liberalisation is necessary and the
results have been quite quite evident so
far that as India liberalizes and it's
particularly Indian states open up their
economies and that's been part of the
part of the movement that everybody
benefits not simply the few people at
the top but there's a significant
economic benefit for everybody down to
the level of the labor and the worker
and the problem is that India's
liberalisation has been so slow that
people haven't seen the results quickly
and I think that this is a gonna be a
difficult problem for New Delhi because
this is a time when the world economies
are shrinking they're not expanding if
India had liberalized ten years earlier
if it had begun this in the late 70s
rather than the early 90s then I think
you would see India pretty much caught
up with China by now
unfortunately India didn't take that
step then and it's it's gonna lag behind
China it's gonna lag behind Taiwan South
Korea a number of other states but I
think that I've I myself have noticed
tremendous increase in prosperity in
India there's also an increase in
poverty in parts of India and the
disparity between the very poor and the
increasingly
new rich in India could create political
problems and I think Indians themselves
have to be sensitive to this they can't
simply get rich themselves and ignore
what happens to their other neighbors I
think this is an important part of being
a democracy
Prime Minister Vajpayee and also General
Musharraf a Pakistan will be in the
united states for the UN General
Assembly that session which was delayed
because of the events of September 11th
and you can watch a number of the
speeches including President Bush
Saturday morning which will kick off the
week of speeches at the UN in New York
here on c-span next call from the Bronx
in New York good morning for Steven
Cohen uh yeah hi mr. Cohen
I had a question how far is India away
from developing a boosted weapon or a
true hydrogen bomb if I knew I probably
be shot I mean and I don't know I mean
these are very sensitive issues both in
India and presumably in the US
intelligence services who might or might
not know something about this I I
couldn't give you a good answer I do
think however that the Indian the
Indians have made this claim that their
weapon was boosted this is a technical
way of expanding their yield of a
nuclear weapon but I think that the
larger problem is the question does
India want to be a major nuclear weapons
state what benefits would this bring to
India and I'm not quite sure if the
political benefits are there certainly
they don't need it for military reasons
unless you believe in nuclear war
fighting I think that the Indians may
well decide to go very slow in
developing their military technology
phasing this out over men of decades not
rush quickly to have an deployed
deployed powerful nuclear program but
they do see this as an emergency
emergency weapon in cases the major
powers including the United States
should turn hostile they would then want
to have a nuclear weapon to defend
themselves or to protect themselves
against American intervention in South
Asia based on your research do you think
that there is a real chance that
pro-taliban forces could move into
Pakistan and get nuclear technology and
is there also a chance in India no I in
India certainly not I me of course the
Taliban are an extremist Islamist Muslim
phenomena have nothing to do with India
ball though there are Hindu extremists
who would supporters look at the Taliban
yeah well there would there would be
Hindu extremists that might be the
counterpart of the tali-bum but I don't
think that's likely at all in India in
India most the people in the indian bond
program that i know her quite rational
sensible people and would certainly
prevent this from happening the case of
Pakistan there was some fear about a
month ago - almost a month and a half
ago that Pakistan was an unstable
country in the musharraf might not last
and that in that under those conditions
it could be that Pakistani nuclear
technology or in fissile material might
escape and get out to some terrorist
group and began ballon - a terrorist
operation of some sort or another I
think there's still that risk I think
that New York and Washington and Chicago
could be subject to a terrorist nuclear
attack not with a weapon so much but
were they Assembly of junk fissile
material the way the Egyptians built a
bomb in the 1950s which would dust our
cities with radiation I know
wonder if that's true or not but it's
something we should be concerned about
this book published by the Brookings
Institution press it's called emerging
power India its author is Stephen Cohen
and our next call is Houston good
morning good morning good morning good
morning mr. Cryan
I have a small question what about
Kashmir do you think it's a freedom
struggle I like the way you put the
question and my answer would be yes in
that it is both at the same time it is a
freedom struggle that in to the degree
that some Indian Kashmir is felt that
they were being oppressed by India and
in in Indian policy in Kashmir was
abominable no question about it
they they rigged elections they bribed
they corrupted people and a group of
young Kashmiri yunkish marries who
participate in one of these elections
missense decided that this is too much
they broke away and went to Pakistan for
support they came back in launched aid a
campaign against the Indian government
so that was that was in a sense a
freedom struggle and of course the
Indian government doesn't see it that
way but my perspective these were the
they had legitimate grievances against
the Government of India
there were also there's all it's also a
terrorist issue in that the Pakistanis
have allowed many groups from
Afghanistan and Pakistan in other
countries even even there even some
British Muslims who are involved in here
to come into a come into Kashmir and
their goal isn't the liberation of
Kashmir from India their goal is to
promote an Islamic Revolution and their
target is not simply the independence of
Kashmir
or to give Kashmir better status within
India but their target is to create a
revolution among Indian Muslims and
beyond that a revolution among Muslims
all over the world so I think that's a
very very dangerous phenomena and that
is in a sense something quite different
than a than a freedom struggle so it is
both a a Messianic Messianic group of
revolutionaries who would like to see an
islamic revolution take over all of the
world including beginning with India and
it's also I think in part at least it
used to be that's a more or less
legitimate struggle by a group of India
Kush marries of Indian origin who felt
that they were being discriminated
against and abused by the Indian
government Los Angeles good morning to
you all right
actually I have a comment to make about
I come from India historically Indians
have been very tolerant and you know
acceptable to other religions and other
people we've been invaded by moguls and
other other you know religious minded
people long time ago
and there have been so many conversions
and historical Indians have been the
Hindus which have been living with other
religious factions and then we had
invasions signed off by British and we
have been living with Christians could
have been converted the portrayal by the
outside media is that the Hindus are
extremists and killing Sikhs and Muslims
is misrepresented because most of the
things that happen are reactionary to
the operations by the other religious
groups in India against Hindus would you
agree with that assessment I agree with
it I agree that 75% are you absolutely
correct that India's one of the more
tolerant accepting societies in the
world and that's the way it has to
operate because if it was not tolerant
it would have broken up a long time ago
there's so many creeds and so many
religions so many different groups in
India they have to learn to live
together that's one of the great
qualities of Indian society however
there are elements especially in the
Hindu community but also where there
were in the Sikh community as well who
are very intolerant who do not do not
accept them there's some Hindu
extremists who do not accept Muslims or
Christians as legitimate Indians because
they feel that they're originally Hindus
were converted to these to these alien
religions and they have physically and
forcefully tried to reconvert people
they've assassinated several
missionaries they burned down Christian
Christian churches there I would put
them in the same category as the Taliban
they are in a sense Hindu Taliban
they're very small group of the Indian
population and a small group of the
Hindu population but they do exist and
it doesn't it doesn't help to pretend
that they don't exist and this has
created a great amount of tension in
India in the past in the past ten years
I was in India 1993 when these groups
tore down the Babri Masjid and
and an old an old mosque that was built
by built in this I guess 17th or 18th
16th or 17th century that's triggered
off anti-muslim riots all over India
thousands of Muslims were killed in the
worst communal rioting that India had
ever seen so I think that you're correct
that India is a reasonably tolerant
society but there are these there there
are these aberrations the same as in the
United States
we're reasonably tolerant society yet we
were attacking and assaulting Muslim
looking individuals than during after
the World Trade Center bombings which
was which was a blot on our record so I
think even democracies even good
democracies do to have to watch their
behavior and these kinds of issues and I
think Indian performance has been good
but no country is perfect an email from
a gentleman and Conover North Carolina
says are Christians and Muslims really
free to practice their religion in India
yeah by and large there's no question
there's no question that they can
practice their religion without without
inhibition there have been these
incidences and in the past Russia in the
past 10 years but for the most part this
is an India has a large free Christian
society there the Christians are very
nervous about growing Hindu chauvinism
they're right in a right-wing
nationalist Hindu chauvinism and Muslims
are also concerned about this as well
but you know wonder I think one of the
great qualities of India is that it's
such a complex country it is so big and
so vast that these elements tend to
balance each other out over the long
term in that sense they resemble it
resembles the United States our next
call Sacramento California good morning
good morning
how are you I have a question that India
has a diverse type of economy and people
are either very poor or sometimes very
rich though it has a lot of talent
India has a lot of talented people but
do you think that this kind of economy
we're very diverse does it make India
lagging behind in the progress thanks
college yeah I think that the
characterization is a very poor invert
or very riches is inaccurate he has a
huge middle class that is ordinary
Indians who have regular businesses jobs
work in governments or teach or middle
class employment for middle-class
professionals so gigantic middle class
and it's variously estimated at two to
five hundred million people it's not an
insignificant middle class
they have middle-class values
middle-class aspirations they want their
kids to go to school they're worried
about being poor but they they have
enough to get by they acquire consumer
goods television sets motor scooters
perhaps even cars so I think that I
think that there's a giant middle class
and that in fact is the basis of Indian
democracy that plus the fact that the
poorest of India understand that their
vote is important so India has a
functioning democracy based on not so
much a few rich people but a giant
middle class that sees politics as
essential to their to their values and
their freedoms and any much larger
poorer element of Indian society that
sees politics as a vehicle for
advancement and one remarkable thing
about India is the high turnout rate of
Indian of Indian voters and they vote
much in much larger numbers than
Americans vote and then the poorest
Indians have hydro not heard how your
voting turnout rates it's a lesson we
can learn from because they see politics
as useful to them and they participate
in politics and India has a mass film
industry for example which is
essentially based on the middle classes
of India and the poor class of India so
I don't think that it's it's it's that
highly stratified society there are some
rich there are many many poor there's
this giant middle class which really I
think is one of the bases of Indian
democracy we have time for one more call
New York City good morning for Stephen
Cohen hello good morning
yes am I on the air yeah yes good thank
you very much mr. Cohen I I first of all
I want to make one statement that before
the Western powers interfere in internal
affairs of India they should know a
little bit of the history of India India
was basically a Hindu land it has been
bashed again and again and again by
rulers like specially the Muslim rulers
God knows where they came from that's
how we had the mobile period and then
the British came and they roll India for
200 years and in 1947 when they left
they divided the country into India and
Pakistan Pakistan was created as a state
for Muslim people and the Muslims we
have now in India they prefer to stay in
India they should go away and nothing
fish means fish mean is a part of India
and fish means there's a history behind
Kashmir fish meat is a land of Hindus
Brahmins pundits and pundits are Hindus
and the reason we have these Muslims
because they stayed behind the
the remnants of the Mogul period before
the British came to India and when India
was divided when the Muslim Pakistan was
created in 1947 they were asked to leave
the country and all the Hindus 90
percent of the Hindus from Pakistan came
into India but these Muslims were stayed
behind and if they do not like Kashmir
the Muslim people and because India
isn't in Kashmir is an integral part of
India they do not like India they should
go well Stocki there thanks for the
comment I would just say you might want
to read my book I discuss these issues
carefully I'm frightened by your
statement that Indian Muslims should
leave India there would be 140 million
people having to pick up and go
someplace else I think that does not do
justice to the Indian Constitution into
the Indian leadership I've never heard
that kind of statement from any
responsible Indian leader I think that
Indian Muslims can and should live in
India's you enjoying the full rights of
India fact most of them were originally
Hindus they've converted to Islam for
various reasons I don't think because of
that they should be discriminated
against or persecuted or driven out of
their homeland in one of your closing
chapters you say this if India used to
be easy to rule but hard to change now
it is quick to change but difficult to
govern yes I mean in Indian politicians
have developed the art of governance to
a fantastic degree they're able to
operate a country which is incredibly
complicated and then their task is made
more difficult by the fact that India
itself is changing very quickly this is
a series of domestic revolutions going
on in India an economic revolution a
caste revolution of federal revolution
between the centre in the States and I
think an ideological revolution with the
rise of people with the rise of Hindu
nationalism this is made into very
exciting country it's also made into a
very inward-looking country and I think
that it's it's a full time job for
Indian politicians to manage these these
simultaneous revolutions but I think
they're doing a remarkable job in fact
if other states in the world especially
in the Middle East had the kind of
democracy that India has I think we'd be
would be a lot of our problems in terms
of terrorism would would be solved this
is the book it's called emerging power
India our guest has been Stephen Cohen
of the Brookings Institution thanks for
being with thank you Steve appreciate it